ARE IP
MATT GAETZ'O
WOIM. PAULA REED IS OUT FRONT
WITH ALL THE LATE DEVELOTSHIS C.
>> Reporter: THE FEDERAL ST FLOG
CRIMES INCLUDING AN ALLEGELAELA
S MAN, JOEL GREENBERG.A TAX COL
AND HE INTRODUCED THWHH PAYMENTE
GAETNEVER PAID FOR SEX  ALL
DISGUSTING ALLEGATIONS
COMPLETELY.
>> PROVIDING FOR FLIGHTS ANDHOT
DATING OF LEAG A
CRIME.
r:OURC
CNN, INVESTITEORS ARE EXAMINING
AMIS
YING FORL AND
EXPENSES WOMEN.
GAETZ AND GREENBERG HAD BEEN YE
SEVENTH RICT.
SHE GE RECORDG ESSAGE TO S IS E
R AND I P IN THE
PANHANDLE WITH YOUR CONGRESSMAN
>>ERED A
PLEA OF NOT GUIL.
ATEY
GAETZ NO.
IN ADDIT,  PWOPT WITH.IGATION,
GAETZ SHARED IMAS ON HIS PHONE
E ON THE FLOOR OHOUSE.
ALLIES.OUND HIEW
HIS COMMUNICATIONS DIREC
RESI T
REMAINED SILT AMID O SCLA
ND>>F ALL TRUEY YOU ARE WIT.
KATY, LET ME STA WU.
YOU REEDT MESSAGES A
THESENT RETSN TOLD THEIR FRIEND
TRANSACTION MORE DID YOLEARN A
ENCOUN?>> WELF THTE
MESSAGE  IS THAT THE MSAS
CLEAR.
ST MEE AT THIS
CAVE THOUSAND
HE THOSE MONEY
WOULOR SOMETHING ELSE.
ITE
THEY WERE PAID FOR.
THE MESSAGES COU BE
CLEARER AND AT LEAST PE RE
MEETING IN A HOTEL MONEY WAS
GOING TO CHANGNDS.EA A LOTF SE
DENIED THON.ER UD.
O
DIFFERENT TIMES, D
HOLSOCATIONS AND SHE
JUGS I GANHERS
E HAVING SEXTHIS BE TO
THE , THISUSEVENING,K WHERE IT
VALUE
PROVIDOR THE S YOUFIC
FURTHER THAN TE I KNOWFLIGHTS O
SOME PEOPLY  SHOWS A COERCION BA
WHEN IT S  TOT MORE PROTECTION T
O PROVE THATATWI UNDERAGED
GIRL, THAT'S THE T
YOU NEEDO HAVE THEIF LIKE THE
ONE KATY WAS
ERENCING
BU IN A JAILL AT THE TIME  WERED
ITG FOR HIL ING THE SAME 1YEAR-
GIRL, HE MAY WANT'S
PROSEHAE HE
OU POINTUTE ENCE FOR THESES IF
COAR
THERE WOULD BE AININDY
IF THAD
>> ABSOLUTELY.
FOR JOEL GREENG S  PN MATT
TO LIFE THERE IS ANOER ELEMENT,
URG WAS CHARGED WITHTITY THEFT,D
OTHER THGSULD BE
GUILTY AS JOEL GREENBUHEE SAMESD
IMT JOELCO
ER NO ODERE
ANRE VOOIS I                   H
ULTOID A
ON SENTENCHERE.  TTH
I WA T
MESSAGE GAETZ AND GREENBURG
MAT A, THEY ARE TOGETHER DOING
ALL THESR ICTHER FOR FLORIDA STE
>> MY DEAR, THIS IS YOUR LECTOR.
M E WITH
ETZ. T CONGRESAN
A WERETIYOD TALKING ABOUT YOURF
THE DEMOCRATICKATY, OU
, YO
U , HA
BUDDIES.
MEAN, WE Y
WELLY CLOSE FRIENDS.
WE KNOW THEYE D PART
UPPEECHELONS.EF FLORIDA  GROUPME
HIFRE COUNTY
X COLLR  AS
THTHEY ARE TIGTHEY WERE CLOSURSE
EN THEY WERE SHARING
WOMEN TOTH WONE OF THE OTHER IN
NST , NOLY G HAVE SECTION WH BU
HAVEO.
NO OUR RWOMAN THAT CLAIMS TO HA
SEX WITH AND S AGREED .
AR
WIELSE WAS
FRIENDS WITH THESE GENTLEM
WOULD WANT TO HAVE THIS KIND OF
TSRIGHT, >> WELL,.
YO THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED AND THEN
WITH YOU AND YO FUR FRIEND AND
AMMING AND SORTED,  COURSE.AS TM
THEFE SAID
THE CALL WAS QTETO
RE CALFROM
YOU SORT OF KNOW THE PYERS.
ATU ING ON
WITH THIS CALL?
HEY WERE TROLLING
HE AY YOUNG.
SHE'S 30 RIGHT
STVE, THE FIRST
EVER
REPRESENTATIVE IN RE
SANDERS WING OF THE DEMOCRATIC
BTEOU HREPUBLICANS  IN
SHE'S THE FUTURE OF THE
WEYOYOTO UNDERSTIMATE ANNA BECA
THAT USED TO BE HELD BA INS BY R
UNDE HER. LLING AN